okay have a look with me these points
here right claim at two this circle the
unit circle you can define them right
using the coordinates here cos theta
sine theta and this is a parametric
definition it relies on knowing what
theatre is okay now so far all six of
the equations then I've got for defining
this motion this motion right they're
all in terms of a parameter it's not
theta though it's time right so there's
time sort of built into this this
diagram young right now to go from here
to here right I would say look I don't
need to worry about a parametric
definition of this shape it's a very
simple shape that I know it's a circle
right so I could define it in a
Cartesian way like this x squared plus y
squared equals one that's a definition
without the parameters okay
the equation apart is exactly the same
idea right it says look I know what this
shape is and I don't need to worry about
the parameter time I can just say that's
a parabola and I know what kind of
incredible it is as well how are you
gonna go about doing it you got two
alternatives number one you can say
we'll look I'm at zero zero right and
what is the coordinate over here we've
worked it out in the process of the
question what is it it's two zero isn't
it didn't we say that Adam was two
meters away from Steve that's what we
concluded right so you can do that and
then you need one more point to define a
parabola because there's an infinite
number of crabbers that goes through
those two points what might be a good
idea to choose probably this guy up here
right which would be by my reckoning
that'll be one and how do we have fun up
did we go also one right so you can use
those three points and you can define a
problem easy okay
but that's partly because the
coordinates is usually you don't get
away so lucky okay so in a situation
like this how would I go from here to
here how do I get rid of a parameter
yeah you need to do something to do some
substitution right in this case you
would square and you use the Pythagorean
identity okay we're going to do
something similar here but we're going
to take our X equation and our Y
equation sorry minus 5t squared plus 250
I think okay that's what we're gonna do
so I want to get rid of the parameter
when I get rid of all the T's right so
probably the best way to fit this is X
into y because the Y equations have been
a mess right
so I say T equals x hundred five SS yes
okay I get it just from the horizontal
displacement so now I could take all of
the t's here and replace them - five
there's T squared plus two hundred five
times and there's t again yep okay
square root of five squared v 5s cancel
minus X square root fives cancel plus 2x
that looks about right doesn't it okay
like I said of course you end up with a
simple equation because there were
simple numbers right but sometimes this
mess here ends up pretty awful right I
think I think you probably got
introduced to the minus B G cos alpha
blah blah blah blah right all of that
right is kind of a shortcut way of
arriving at this point can you see that
the only reason we could do this is
because we spent like four or five parts
of the question developing what this is
and developing one this is so it takes
time
okay but you can go here directly if you
know what all of these things are
everything over here completely defines
the situation